Trump has been touting a 51% approval
rating from some very specific
right-leaning pollsters but the reality
is that Donald Trump's approval rating
has dropped to its lowest in 2019 which
is 36%
this is looking at one poll that has
been done over time it's The Associated
Press poll it's been tracking Trump's
approval for his entire presidency and
right now
Trump's approval is 36% his disapproval
is 62%
so let's contextualize this let's
explain why it matters and then let's
talk about how it relates to 2020 first
of all the context Trump's approval has
been in the range of 32 to 42 in The
Associated Press poll since day one so
it didn't go lower than 32% approval
it's never been higher than 42 percent
approval that's a small range of only 10
points that one one thing that relates
to is the hyper partisanship and
polarization in the United States
politically we've talked about that
before
right now Trump is at 36 that's pretty
close to the middle of that 32 to 42
range a little bit on the lower end and
that ties the lowest approval of 2019 so
is this some kind of breaking news that
changes everything Trump approval at 36
well not in the sense that Trump is in
the middle of the approval range that
he's had all presidency secondly some
partisan context if you look at
Democrats 95 percent disapprove of Trump
Republicans approve 79 percent and
independents approve 65% that's an
important number the 79 percent that
Republicans approve this is important
because Trump's been touting and
Republicans have been leaning on Trump
has 95 percent approval among
Republicans I don't know what poll that
is this is a good poll that we're
looking at and it says hold on a second
79 percent of Republicans approve of
Trump this matters in the context of a
primary challenger which now Donald
Trump has in former Congressman Joe
Walsh and I'll be talking about that
later in the show
95 percent approval from your party and
79 percent approval from your party are
two very different things and in a
I marry the goal of which would be not
to defeat Donald Trump in the primary
it's not going to happen but to do some
damage to Trump that is going to be
significantly influenced by the
difference between Republicans approving
of Trump 79 percent versus 95 percent so
that's important also important there
are three areas where Republicans
actually disapprove of Trump's handling
more than they disapprove of him overall
so again remember 79 percent of
Republicans approve of Trump
however only 77 percent think he's
handling health care correctly only 75
percent say he's handling foreign policy
correctly and only 70 percent believe
he's handling gun policy correctly this
is important and it's interesting but
Republicans are not going to vote for a
Democrat because they disagree with
Trump on these issues this is important
to understand for Democrats gun policy
isn't a voting issue by and large for
Republicans gun policy can be a voting
issue if you are on the wrong side of
more guns in more places but the reality
is if you're a Republican and you don't
love Trump's take on guns you're not
gonna go and vote for a Democrat over
that that's the reality
Healthcare a lot of these Republicans
25% of them they might recognize Trump
is completely bungling healthcare but
they're not going to go and vote for a
so-called socialist health care plan
from a Democrat they're still gonna vote
Trump they just don't like what he's
doing on health care
similarly foreign policy foreign policy
is just not a voting issue in the way
that domestic economic issues are so
that gets us to what do we do with this
data whether it's 36 percent approval or
32 percent approval or even in the
twenties Donald Trump can still win
reelection
I've I've run the numbers before with
you half the country doesn't vote you
could have a 26 percent approval and
turnout 1% more voters in some key
states than the other party and win
because half the country doesn't vote so
following Donald Trump's approval is
relevant and it helps us to understand
how people especially Republicans are
reacting to Trump it does not tell us
any
thing about what's going to happen in
2020 all you need to know is that Donald
Trump could have a 36 percent approval
rating and easily win and by the way the
fact that he has a 36 percent approval
rating tells us that there are tens of
millions of people who are so
disconnected from reality
or ideologically blinded that they don't
care what happens in the real world they
are voting for Trump in 2020 period okay
Trump has tens of millions of votes in
2020 already it's August of 2019 the
elections in November of 2020 Trump has
tens of millions of votes once you know
that you realize this becomes
get-out-the-vote because we're not going
to be able to convince these people in
any large numbers I know I'm a broken
record at this point I've been talking
about this for so long this is going to
be about get out the vote that needs to
be our priority in our context heading
into 2020 tell me if you think there is
some other way in which Trump's approval
is relevant beyond reminding us he's got
tens of millions of votes in the bank
already and we've got to get the vote
out follow us on instagram at
instagram.com slash david pakman show
and oh I have a new story on my
Instagram page David Pakman got back
from vacation big developments with my
tomato plants huge developments make
sure you're following me on instagram at
instagram.com
slash david hackman